a materialist believes that matter is  the fundamental element of reality in  the history of existence first we had  matter incapable of thought out of which  developed thinking matter AKA humans our  thoughts do not appear until we already  have matter organized in a certain  manner the human organism is matter  organized in a very sophisticated way so  because of the historical existence of  matter before the thinking human our  mind is just matter that operates in a  specific manner the reason materialists  are so adamant about this is because  they want to emphasize on what is this  worldly and abstain from many  metaphysical explanations of the world  around us